>> This session is about
continuous deployment.
What we're going to do is look at
it from three perspectives.
The sort of 10,000
feet where we go Professor
Laurie Williams,
and he's been working
with multiple
companies as he's been
running it so much that
we should talk about.
So it's actually across
industry on how they
apply these methods on
the problems they have.
We're also going to have a talk
by Bing, by shopaholics.
Bing is the classic continuous
deployment type product
where you got service
with very little on-prem,
so that's like the
1,000-foot perspective.
Then finally, we
have Office which is
probably the most difficult
thing to deploy,
and Jen [inaudible] is going
to give a talk on that.
Since it's sort of three talks
on very similar subject,
then instead of taking
questions from each
of the speakers,
what we're gonna do is we'll
take no questions during
the each speakers,
and then right at the end,
we'll have all three speakers up
and then we can ask questions
from the same thing.
Because you probably
will be asking
roughly the same question from
each of the same speaker,
so it's a lot easier
to just have them
all up and speaking.
So first off, we have
Professor Williams to talk
about Challenges in
Continuous Deployment.
>> Thanks Brandon. Thanks all
for coming to this session.
Since you came to a continuous
deployment session,
you probably know what it is.
But I'm going to
start out just by
defining it, just in case.
So this is a pipeline,
and with continuous deployment,
when a developer makes a change,
it goes through a number
of automated checks
starting with unit tests,
could be code review,
that could be a number of
different checks that are
supposed to be happening
without any human intervention.
So it goes from a developer to
actual customers, no
human intervention.
It happens in some companies
in a matter of minutes.
Like some companies deploy
hundreds or even thousands
of times of day.
Some it's less often.
The point is to get
feedback back to
the developers as
quickly as possible.
But from a definition standpoint,
continuous deployment says
no human intervention.
Related continuous delivery is
similar except there are
some manual checks along the way.
So I am randomly put
some manual steps in here,
could be at any point,
but continuous delivery says you
haven't yet achieved
continuous deployment.
From another term standpoint,
you may hear also DevOps a lot.
DevOps is an
organizational structure
where the operations people who
do the deployment collaborate
much more closely
with the developers.
So I'd say DevOps
is an organizational
structure that would go
around or could go around
both continuous deployment
and continuous delivery.
Brandon mentioned that I've
been running what I call
the Continuous Deployment Summit
in Silicon Valley over
the last four years.
On this slide are
17 companies that have
participated in the summit.
In the four years,
they could've participated one,
two, three or four times.
If you look at the companies,
a lot of them you'll know,
some of them you won't,
but we intentionally choose
companies for the summit
that cross the spectrum of
large company to small company,
from companies that
I would say we're
born doing continuous
delivery and
continuous deployment
like Facebook,
Netflix, Google, they never
did anything but that.
Although they still
have challenges.
To companies that like,
as Brandon mentioned,
there's Windows, it's
a large monolithic product
and Bing in the same company.
Again, a spectrum.
We have companies like Cisco,
IBM, and SAS that have
large monolithic products.
The uniting factor of
all the companies is that
they all want to use
continuous deployment types of
practices to improve
their efficiency,
to get value to the
customers quicker,
and to get feedback
back to the developers.
They all have struggles,
even though the ones like
I said, Facebook, Google,
Netflix that started that way,
they still have struggles, they
still want to be more efficient.
As far as the years,
the first year was in
Facebook, second year Google,
third year Netflix, and Brandon
hosted at Microsoft
just this past Monday.
So I couldn't do my slides ahead
of time because it just happened.
So what I'll be sharing with
you are the challenges that
the company has talked about
in the Continuous
Deployment Summit.
It's not just about
challenges though,
there actually are some benefits.
So I'll start out with
the benefits and then
spend most of the time
on the challenges.
So the companies that they
use these practices
some of the benefits,
first of all, relate
to the engineers.
So the engineers are happier,
they get feedback quicker,
they feel more empowered,
and generally they
like working that way.
Although we'll talk about
culture in a little bit.
The company gets a lot
of value because they're
continuously sending value
out to the customers,
giving them new functionality
on a regular cadence.
They don't have
big release stress
because the releases are
happening all the time.
If a function doesn't
make this release,
it can make the one
this afternoon,
and so you don't have
a type of release stress.
The companies themselves,
the attendees,
said that they feel they have
quality and
productivity benefits,
although we don't have
empirical evidence of that.
But that's the way they felt.
That the focus on
automation towards
getting to the
continuous deployment,
that automation- they
view it as a benefit,
the focus on automating more
and more of the practices.
Quicker mean time to repair,
so if there is a problem,
the ability to get a fix to
a customer quick is a benefit.
So they have this
deployment pipeline
where they're continuously
getting change out,
and so if there's a problem,
they just follow the normal
process and get the change out.
To me, one of
the biggest differences that
you can see with that
is back it was 2014,
so it was a while ago,
there were security
problems found both with
Jeeps and with Tesla,
within two weeks of each other.
So for the Jeep,
when there was
a security problem,
Chrysler sent USB sticks
out to all the customers,
all the car owners, 1.4
million USB sticks
went to car owners.
What do you think happened
to those USB sticks?
Right? How many of them
actually were used?
How many of them
were thrown away?
How many of them were repurposed?
Within that same timeframe,
couple weeks later,
Tesla had a different problem,
but a security problem,
they fixed it up over the air.
So they have the ability
to do something like that,
and any of the
companies that have
this continuous deployment
pipeline have
the ability to get
fixes out quickly.
Then, in general,
developers get feedback.
So those are the benefits.
Now we'll talk about
the challenges for companies.
On the first challenge is,
what happens when you
have a large change?
So part of continuous deployment
includes continuous integration.
So when a developer
makes a change,
they are always integrating.
They're not keeping things on
their own machine,
on the sandbox,
on a different branch,
they're actually
integrating the change
into the main branch.
So what happens when
you have a big change?
Well, generally,
what is done is it's
a feature toggle is put
around that change,
so that the developer can
continue to integrate
their changes without the
customer experience changing,
and they can keep
developing that way.
So I have architecture changes,
any large feature changes,
database changes are
all done this way.
What this picture is
really showing is,
and this is a little
bit of classic
with a database schema change,
that what can be
happening is you're
using one database and
then when you make a change
that has a schema change,
then you put a feature
flag around it and,
potentially, what's happening is
now that for testing purposes,
you're sending it to bolt
the paths at the same time,
that bolt databases
are being populated.
Then when you feel good about it,
then you take
the old database away.
That's similar to any kind
of large architectural
change as well.
You can be having
potentially traffic going
to the new architecture,
you're testing
the new architecture,
but the users can't see it yet.
So it is a testing strategy
where you're testing in
production which we'll
talk about more as well.
But this is really
enabled by the use of
feature toggles and the way
that you direct the traffic.
Another challenge
and a perception is
if you're making all these
changes so quickly,
what happens to
privacy and security?
A couple of things
to say about that.
First is organizational.
The organizational is
really on this slide.
So in many organizations,
those security people,
they're in a separate group
and they're not integrated.
Another strategy is
SecDevOps where now
it's not just DevOps
but the security people are in
there as part of the team as
well and tightly integrated.
So, one, from an
observational standpoint,
you would think these continuous
deployment companies might
be on the leader of the
DevSecOps movement,
but really not so.
There's not a lot
of evidence of them
having security
integrated as tightly.
So, if you take it from
a representative standpoint,
probably DevSecOps is
more of an idea at
this point than really implemented
in a lot of companies.
One change that we've seen over
the four years of the Summit
is that the security people
are being more integrated,
that they are being
more partnered
with as opposed to as
early in the years,
it was more like
those security people
they just stop our releases.
Now, there's more of a
partnership that's taking place.
So, that may be representative
of companies as a whole
as security is being
more of excelled,
more of a partner and not
just stopping releases.
So, that's organizational
standpoint.
The way that the companies
deal with security and privacy
changes through some
of them anyway is,
if a change has a security or
privacy implication, that again,
they put a feature toggle around
that change and it is not
visible to the public
until the security or
privacy people look at
that change and okay it and
then they release the flag.
So, that's the way that they,
in general, control that.
Another thing that
I would say some of
the more advanced
companies including
Bing and Windows as
you'll see, do feature
experimentation.
So, feature experimentation is
where the company are putting
out potentially
multiple versions of
the same thing or trying
a new feature and
trying to get data that
would say whether
the customers have,
they like the change or not.
So, this is a Netflix screen and
Netflix is a big company
that does feature
experimentation.
It's possible that if you and I
sat down with
our laptops and pulled
up Netflix at this minute
our screens would be different,
because they're continuously
trying new things
out and they're watching
where we hover,
how long we stay and all
kinds of things about what we do,
and then they can keep a
change or not keep a change.
So, in a lean startup,
pivot or persevere,
they're collecting data,
instrumenting code,
collecting data,
making decisions.
Sounds good, but it's
more complicated.
So, some of the complications,
back in the early days
of the Summit,
we actually wrote an iTripoli
software paper and one of
the adages we put
in the paper was
"Every feature is an experiment."
That's the idealistic view.
Now it's like, "Well, maybe not
every feature is an experiment",
because there's just, the cost of
instrumenting code and
collecting all the data,
which could be every change you
might have 1,000
different metrics,
and then the use of
guardrail metrics,
is what Microsoft calls it,
where if there's something
that hits either
the high or low to say
some big change has taken place,
then you have to get
alarmed to think of
what has that change
done and take it out.
The experiment, even
for companies large
like Google or Netflix that
have many many customers,
they can't just run it to get
a good enough sample size,
because we behave differently
in the morning than
we do at night.
We behave differently on
a Monday than we do on a Sunday.
So, they have to have
longer periods of
time where they're testing
these features out.
So, in general,
experimentation is
more complicated than it was
originally thought about.
So, with all that,
the experimentation
has feature toggles,
architecture database changes
have feature toggles,
security has feature toggles,
there's other types
of feature toggles.
The companies do admit that
when you have these experiments,
if it's a failed experiment,
say no, don't make that change,
they might just take
that code and turn
the flag off and
leave the code there.
So, now it's dead code,
if you will, that's
hanging around.
So, just all of the code that is
hidden behind feature toggles can
remain there causing
technical debt.
So, you can't have a movement
underway, potentially,
to identify these
areas of the code
that have this dead code,
essentially, and
try to remove it.
They can cause a problem
because someone
might see some code
there and say,
"I like that code",
but because it's behind
a feature toggle they're
not sure if they
can depend on that code or
not depend upon that code.
So, in general, the complexity
that's added with all of
these feature toggles,
the complexity and technical
debt needs to be considered.
Some radically
different types of testing.
So, as I mentioned earlier,
unit testing is done
much more often,
which is a good thing,
but there are other
testing strategies.
So, testing strategies
would say that,
"You put this code down
in production behind
a feature flag and you
test it through the API."
So, when I think about what we
teach students at university,
we're not teaching them about
doing something like that.
We're teaching them about deploy
your code and then
test it in production.
Some companies say
they have to test in
production because they
need that level of scale,
they need to be on
production servers to make
sure that it's working properly.
So, deploy it out there through
a dark launch so the users
can't see it and
test it that way,
but then the next
level of testing
is as you're deploying
the changes.
So, continuous deployment
companies typically may dog
food a change so it's only
visible to own employees,
and then when that works,
then deploy it to a 0.5
percent of the population,
one percent of the population,
five percent of the population.
You're watching to
see how it reacts,
which that's a form of
testing in production.
You're looking at the types
of changes and defects,
and pulling back potentially or
rolling a new version out
quickly to take care of a change.
Mobile deployment is
definitely a challenge.
So, they can even say,
"Web development,
we got that one", but mobile
deployment is harder.
The Play Stores, they do
not allow you to
continuously deploy changes.
A company may only be able
to make a new
version once a week.
So you can't have
the same type of strategy.
So, they have to be
more careful with
their quality for
their mobile deployment.
Also, they have to consider
that on mobile devices,
you may take a version and you
may never take another version.
So, there can be
an infinite amount of
different versions
out on the customers.
I mean, they even
talked about TVs,
said it would be
cheaper, Netflix says,
"It would be cheaper for
us to buy all the TVs back
with some of the versions on
them than to maintain
those versions."
So, there was this change in
this year where people
were talking about apps
being built with
a much thinner Client
and more JavaScript, more code,
so that what's on the phone or
on the mobile device itself is
smaller and everything
else being on
a JavaScript or on the server,
and the feature flags being
able to be changed so that
you don't actually have
to deploy a new version
on the phone or on
the mobile device,
you just change the feature flags
centrally in order to take
care of some of these concerns.
Then the last one
is tool investment.
There's a lot of focus on tools,
open-source tools to control
the deployment pipeline.
There's Chaos Monkey tool where
there are companies,
particularly Netflix,
are injecting instability into
the network to see what would
happen and the companies
share these types of tools,
but yet all of the companies have
large IT organizations as well,
in order to support
continuous deployment.
The whole pipeline, the
automated unit tests,
the automated static analysis,
any fuzzing, those are tools,
I mean that from a
research standpoint,
the companies are really
looking for good tools
and management of false positive,
that type of thing so
they can put it in
the tool chain and not
need human intervention.
So, from a research standpoint,
there's a lot of need there.
Then the last one, Culture Shift.
Culture shift in that now
the developers are the ones
that are typically
called when a problem surfaces,
where before it used to be like
those support people
handle the field problems.
Now, it's usually, "I
integrated something today,
it caused a problem.
I need to deal with it," which
means the developers
seem to be much
more cognizant of their quality
and putting out
high quality products,
which is a good thing.
But on the other hand, it adds
another level of stress
they didn't used to have,
which is not always a good thing.
Then, just in general,
the new types of development
that happen with
continuous deployment,
it just causes
a huge culture change,
which not all of
the people say it's,
they actually say it's
the toughest thing of all.
It is the big culture change
because of all of
the different things that
the developers have to do
that they didn't used to do.
They talked about having
shows where they go from
location to location talking
to the development team,
sending someone with a success
story to another location.
VMware, they talked
about going from,
in this journey, going from
multiple branches to one branch.
So, they killed
the branches and they
had some ceremony where
they had cupcakes
with coffins on them
and brought them to
all the locations for a ceremony
for killing the branches to
make lighthearted of it.
But they say the culture changes
are actually quite hard.
To summarize, lots of changes in
a way changes everything.
But there's a lot
of opportunity in
those changes along
with the challenges.
>> So, one of the things
in the summary is that
most people have
very similar problems
because it's difficult.
When you have large software,
it's just difficult to have
to change it with
so many different people.
So, Bosses say is having
that range of different types
of Product types is
quite useful to learn
how effective CD is
and how ineffective
is if at a time so,
Bing has a different perspective
on this. Chap, join in.
>> Hello everybody.
So, I'm from Bing,
we're going to be talking
specifically about Bing UX,
so if you've ever gone to Bing,
thank you for your support.
Everything you see
is built on top of
the platform that we're
going to discuss
a little bit here today.
So, some of the core
Bing wide principles;
Life-site quality is paramount.
We were our brand is the quality.
If we have bad quality,
people will go elsewhere.
We're a second place
in a difficult race,
so everything we do has
to be high-quality.
We always are looking to
innovate and produce new things.
Again, it's a competition
and we need to make sure
that we're keeping pace,
we need to find
differentiators that
draw people toward
us. Data rules.
So, some of the things that
Laurae was just talking about,
you're going to see echoes
of it, it's really cool actually.
Data is what we use,
we can't use emotion because if
we're automating everything,
there's no emotion.
So, we have to make sure
that we pay attention to
the data and we have to believe
the data and we have
to use the data.
Search is an expensive business,
it's complicated,
it's very expensive
to run and so,
everything that we can do to
improve it to make things
a little bit better,
a little bit faster, a little bit
more automated is what we go for.
So, here's a high level of
the Bing serving stack.
It's a multi-tier stack.
They are hosted in servers,
do distributed
around the world and
each tier is on its own
deployment cadence,
as well as their own codebase.
We handle ingress,
routing, and throttling,
and then the UX rendering tier,
data query and
aggregation and then the
various data-based indexes
at the bottom.
A vertical along that side
is metrics and monitoring.
We're talking today about
the UX data presentation tier.
We have many hundreds
of developers
in this single branch.
We're seeing an
exponential growth over
the last 5-7 years,
precisely because of the success
we've had with improving
Agility and continuous
integration
and continuous delivery.
The UX data and
presentation tiered Bing is
roughly is less than
100 milliseconds
at the 95th overall,
and we render all of the HTML,
we handle the API entry points,
we handle Cortana, handle Yahoo.
There's other deals
with Yahoo and Apple.
So, we just recover
a large space,
is very large monolith.
So, why did Bing
invest in Agility?
This is what I was
just talking about.
We need to stay competitive.
It's a question of survival.
If we can't keep pace,
if we can't differentiate and
innovate faster
than our opponent,
then we're going to continue
to fall by the wayside,
people will just abandon us.
So, I want to keep my job,
I need to support my children,
so I was trying to
do what we can.
We need to make sure
that we're able to
capture more market share.
We run a lot of experiments and
this is another thing
Laurie was talking about,
the emphasis on experimentation,
we run a lot of experience,
thousands of them per month.
Each tier that you saw in
the previous slides
is capable of running
their own experiments and
so there's a lot of things
going on the Bing
stack every day.
So, the question then becomes,
how can we run more experiments?
We need to see
a dramatic increase
in developer productivity.
We need to figure out
a way to make sure that
they are further desk,
getting stuff done, fingers on
the keyboard, making commits.
We need a dramatic increase
in the number of
developers as well.
We've only got five people
who are working on Bing,
we're not going to see
a high pace of innovation,
so we need to get
more people working on it.
Finally, we need to see
a dramatic increase
in experimentation.
So, we need to make sure
that these features,
these experiments
that you're doing are
easily done, easily created,
easily implemented,
easily experiments
are seen in production and then
the data analysis needs
to be simple as well.
So, let's fast-forward five
years, what was the impact?
What was the impact of Agility
and specifically
the Bing UX Agility?
We saw a dramatic increase
in the quality
of the live-site and
this is something
that Laurie was saying as well.
It was almost overnight.
So, we were previously doing
monthly releases which really
not until like every 4-6 weeks.
We wanted it to be
every four weeks but
what would happen is,
we would deploy to the live-site.
There'd be a bunch of things
broken on the live-site,
we'd spend the next week or
two weeks hot fixing them and so,
we always see this delay.
When we switched over to Agility,
it was really impressive,
we went from six or more
live-site incidence per
month to less than
one on average.
We saw that there was an impact
in engineering as well.
The developers are
much more satisfied.
They can see more quickly
the result of their work.
It's no longer
an asynchronous staying
where they check in
something on day one,
it goes out on day 30.
For us, they check in on
something on day one and we
sometimes even get it out on
day one but at the worst
we'll get it out on day two,
and so they have
a very quick feedback loop.
Our pipeline has
also been able to
scale to meet this new demand.
We've actually done a lot of
optimizations to
continue to support
that based on capacity and
resourcing issues that we had.
We also see an impact on
the code base because people
or the developers now are
able to get things
done more quickly.
We see much more
smaller code reviews.
If you're reviewing less code,
you're able to do a better job.
There's fewer files to look
at and fewer changes in each one,
you get a much better
overall code review
than you would for
larger changes.
They're also shorter and more
focused and last but not least,
we've empowered everyone,
Laurie was talking
about culture as well.
We empower everyone to
reject a code review
that doesn't have
tests because the tests
are what we live and
die of the Agility.
This is something Laurie
was saying over and over,
it's the tests that
make the difference.
So, here are some of
the pre-Agility metrics,
this would be from
roughly 2011 or '12.
We had roughly 80 engineers
in our code base.
Some of the more
interesting thing is we had
five different development repos;
one main repo and
a separate release repo.
So, you can imagine
the reverse integrations and
the forward integrations we
tend to do every month
and it would
be a huge delay to try to
get that stuff sorted out.
We were able to ship
once per month.
We had roughly 3,000 tests,
80 percent of which would pass
and they would run ad-hoc.
So, what I've said
in the past is,
we had some tests,
some of which run.
Of those tests that ran,
some of them passed and it was
just a giant question
mark for everything else.
We in terms of the test
tasks that we're able to do,
remember I'm talking
about the Bing UX,
we had less than three browsers.
It was whatever
the developer had on
their machine if they wanted to
do any browser-based
testing at all.
We handled the Bing
Web results and we
would see roughly 10
experiments per month.
Now think about, it
is like it was a choose
your own adventure.
If you wanted to do
effective experimentation
at Bing at that time,
you'd have to say, "Okay,
I'm going to try
this experiment where I change
the link color to purple
and if that one works,
I think I'm going
to try to underline
it but if that one doesn't work,
I think we're going
to try to bold
it and if the bold one
doesn't work,
I think I'm going try
to do this and that."
They would have to do all
of that coding ahead of
time because we only
shipped once a month.
They'd have that
one shot, they get
the code in and then they could
experiment and so they always
had to do much more
work than they needed.
So, that's why we saw
so few experiments.
So, here we are today.
Here we are about when I wrote
this deck, it's 46th now.
We seen over a tenfold increase
in the number of
developers working our branch
and it's basically
because like I said,
they've seen the success,
they've all onboarded
to our repo and so,
there's one repo that
everyone is working in.
We see 15-minute builds,
we see five minutes start times,
and it's 10 minutes to test now,
which was 20 and met
our goal finally.
We have one GIT repo,
it's a mono repo, everyone's
checking into it.
We deliver code 14 times a week,
in fact last week
it was 17 times.
We have 46,000 tests now.
We have four nines and
the tests pass and
auto execution with 14 browsers,
34 devices so you see that
we've been able to get
things done and scale them well
so that we are continuing
to improve things.
Looking at the inner
and outer loops,
the continuous integration,
continuous delivery,
both highly integrated
with Visual Studio.
In fact, my goal is to
completely integrate
with Visual Studio so
that they have one screen
that they look at all day.
Right now there's
still some variation.
Build and test, deploy staging
and we ship gated by
a 100 percent pass rate.
We test everything up front.
All those 46,000 tests are run at
code review time and if
any test fails, they
don't get checked in.
Our Staged deployments
and we were
talking about staging as well,
we deployed to
a canary environment first,
scale unit by skill unit.
If that passes, then we
deliver the rest in parallel.
So, one of the things that we've
learned is that we
just break stuff,
we broke Visual Studio
for a while.
They've broken us multiple times.
What's nice though is
that our scale actually
determines whether
other partners can scale or not.
But in doing so it
helps to improve
them and them improving
it helps to improve us.
So, we had a really
good relationship with
our Engineering Excellence Team,
really good relationship with
the Visual Studio Team Services
and any of the other partners
that we work with.
We improve everything
that we can.
My team is not afraid to jump
organizational boundaries or jump
to another repo or
to make a change,
to improve it
because we know that
the change improves
it for everybody
else and they're fully
empowered to do
whatever they need.
We know also that scale
magnifies improvements
and regressions.
Great example of that is we
run seven percent of
our tests on the browser.
So the test starts and says,
startup this browser, waits for
the browser to start up
and it runs the test.
That's inefficient right?
If it takes four seconds to
start the browser and we have
46,000 tests then we've
wasted minutes of time.
So, what we've done
is we pre-warmed
the browsers and we have
the browsers already running,
and it tests grabs the next one
and runs it, right?
So, we just find that
we can continue to
improve just because
we want to get faster.
And we play, yes, we
play well with others.
We also got something
coming up with.Net Core.
It's going to be really exciting.
So we decided and we
learned that if you have
fewer moving parts,
again this is some,
what I been saying, if you
have fewer moving parts,
less things can break,
you have much better
standardization
and things run much
more smoothly.
We have one environment to
monitor, that's production.
Even our test environment
is production,
just doesn't take traffic.
And we see that there's
one validation gate,
so like I said,
"If you are trying to check in,
we're going to run all the tests.
If anyone of them fails
you are not checking
in until you fix it."
And all of our tests
are co-located,
meaning that they're right there.
So, there's the production code
and test code right next to it,
there's no separate repo where
we store tests definitions
or test results,
everything is strictly
defined out in our codebase.
Yes. So, how can we optimize
continuous integration?
We took every optimization
we possibly could
and we did that over,
and over, and over.
Everything that we
could find that would
improve even by a minute,
our test pass or build
times is an improvement
that it makes
for these 900 developers who
stands here every day and
are able to move faster.
That's the same as it
was, sorry about that.
We also want to optimize
the outer loop,
so we have metrics that
tell us how much time we're
spending in each part
of the outer loop
so we know what we can improve.
We're reusing the continuous
integration mechanics.
What you saw in
the Visual Studio stuff,
we're reusing Visual Studio
for the outer loop as
well to handle
the deployments for us.
We measure all aspects
of continuous delivery.
If you can't measure something,
if you can't decide
whether you're improving,
it's just bad, right?
So, metrics are super,
super important.
Finally, we remove humans.
So, like I said, automation,
she set it over and
over automation.
If you remove the humans,
you will immediately improve
because now you're forcing
yourself to actually have
operationalized system.
Okay. So, I think this
is the last slide,
I'm getting the signal.
This is it, right?
You implement, then
measure, and then iterate.
This is us over and over,
this is experimentation.
We believe in
experimentation so much that
we actually do it
on our own code.
All the code that I have,
all the code that's
been written is
eventually going to
become obsolete;
we just assume that's the fact.
We're always looking to see what
the next longest pole is,
how can we improve this while
this is longer and
we go after it.
It doesn't matter where
it is, we just chase it.
Yes, loyalty is a myth.
I gave this talk
before and people
weren't happy with that.
I was in a different country.
But, a better way of
saying that maybe is,
they'll go wherever
it makes sense to go.
There's no loyalty to
the people in my branch.
If they don't like
what I'm doing or
if they don't like
the system that I built,
they'll go elsewhere,
it's not that hard.
So, we know that
we're successful,
and we aim to please
those developers
so that they stay
in the branch that
helps us to design
a system that works.
We have multiple feedback
mechanisms as well.
We have different ways
that the developers can
have their voice be heard.
We regularly pull them
and find out what is
the most important thing to
deal with next,
and we chase that.
Oddly enough,
the most important thing
to chase right now is
documentation for us.
Not even an engineering problem,
documentation is
what the developers
are least pleased with now.
So we're making
investments in that to
improve it and there's multiple
different ways that
we're trying to do it.
The end. Thank you.
>> Yes, so it's
no coincidence that everyone,
no coordination between
Chap and Laurie but
the problems are exactly
the same across most
of the industry.
I think it's quite funny you
talked about documentation.
Irene did a study and
somebody talked about,
"Do software and engineering
is very similar to cooking?
And writing the software
is basically
the actual cooking itself and
documentation is the washing up?"
So, that's basically.
Finally, we have Office
on the many different
problems with Office.
All right, Jen.
>> Right. I'm
Jennifer Beckmann and
I am Office Engineering Manager.
I actually previously worked in
Bing with Chap and we drove
that experimentation number
up to thousands of
experiments so it was
lots of fun over there.
Now, I've moved to Office,
I'm in the Office
Fundamentals Group,
which is responsible for
the build, the flighting,
and experimentation,
telemetry, security,
and performance pieces of Office.
Seeing this talk that
we are very far from
being the nice agility that
they've driven over there,
and that's what I'm
excited about doing as
I most recently moved
to Office in December.
But I've been working
with Office for a while.
So when I talk about Office,
you might be wondering, well,
what do you talk about
in terms of Office,
SharePoint or is it the clients?
I'm talking about
the rich clients
so Word, Excel, and PowerPoint.
That's the group that I work
in and that's what I'll
be talking about today.
Exchange and the other services
are whole different story,
they have a different story
around continuous deployment.
But I'm really talking
about the apps,
the apps that are on
your desktop right now,
what you most recently made
your PowerPoint presentation in.
That is what I'm talking about.
How are we dealing with
continuous deployment
and delivery in Office.
I'm going to rewind us
and put us back to 1990.
That was when
the first Office Suite
shipped together, Word,
Excel, PowerPoint.
Before that, two releases
before that shipped
independently,
and in 1990, they put them
all together in a suite and
sold them together as Office.
That was 28 years ago and
we have shipped Office,
her versions of Office every
two to three years since
then for around 11
different releases.
Its about one release
every three years,
the ship cycle was the product
managers who get together,
figure out what features
should go in the product,
developers develop it, and then
we would release it
internally to dog food.
Get feedback, bug fixes,
and then externally,
to audience called
MVPs or insiders,
which are outside of
Microsoft but they are
close collaborators,
they would give us feedback.
We would fix it, stabilize,
and then release it in
a process which we called
RTM release to media.
CDs, discs.
So, that's how most of
Microsoft ship products
over this time frame.
The first version of Office in
1990 shipped in
both Windows and Mac.
Mac and Windows were
two different product units,
two different sets of people,
two different codebases shipping
independently throughout
most of the time.
The web version of
Windows are when
we have Office shipped in 2008,
and the iPhone and Android
version shipped in 2013,
and we handle it all in
the same way at the time.
Office is the mainline
Windows branch,
we'd fork the code and
then they would
work really hard to
make it work on the platform
that was targeted.
That's where our office
is coming from,
that's where most of
the code base was built at C++.
It's a huge code base
and I'll give you
some numbers later.
But in 2015, I pulled up
the Microsoft earning report and
it gives an indication of
where Office was at that time.
Windows XP had just
expired its support,
there was major declines
in the PC business market.
Windows and Office were
often sold together,
so if Windows declined
Office declined,
and that's what
happened to Office.
Windows declined, we saw
the decline in earnings from
Office and also our customers
we're transitioning to O 365,
which is our
subscription service.
In October 2015, that's when
we shipped Office 2016.
This is when we already
knew these things were
happening and this is where
we started to integrate some
of that continuous deployment
and delivery practices that
we were just heard about.
So not too long ago.
So let me give you an idea
of what Office has
been doing and working
on with Office 2016.
I mentioned before
that each one of
the products for shipping
have a different codebase.
Each independently forked,
ran by different teams.
In Office 2016, ever
since we shipped in 2015,
we've been working
on trying to get
all the code into one codebase.
This is not entirely true
but we're working on it.
Most recently,
Mac was integrated into
the Windows codebase.
So, Mac, Windows both
shipped from the same code.
That was January of this year,
first time that Mac
shipped with Windows
in January this year.
So, it's a really
huge accomplishment.
The team has been
working on it for
four years getting the code
together in one place.
In terms of shipping the product,
like I talked about before,
you would bundle all
the features together and say,
"Surprise, these are
all your features."
Now, we're shipping Office
12 times a year instead of
once every three years,
and that's approximately
every month.
The features are
behind the flags.
They're dark. They're not turned
on for our users
until they're ready.
They're out there exposed
with percentage-wise,
so that we can watch to make
sure the quality is high
enough before they
get to everybody.
By the numbers, we are
slightly bigger than [inaudible]
looking at their nose.
Wow, we're quite big.
So, we have 4,000 developers.
We check in one checkin
or I check in
every 20 seconds or so.
We have 1,000 checkins a day.
The codebase is
half a billion lines of code.
Not just code, but
test automation suites,
language proofing is huge.
Tools and engineering systems is
also contributing a lot
to that number there.
The Test Suite runs
about 20,000 jobs,
tens of thousands of scenarios,
and hundreds of thousands
of different configurations
every day to get it
out to customers.
Oh, my field slides
aren't working.
It's probably a reflection
of a feature being exposed wrong.
So, how do we get features
out to customers?
It's actually not a lot different
than what I described before.
We still have audiences.
Dogfood is internal set of
users within Microsoft.
Microsoft gets the product,
then it goes out to insiders
similar to our MBP audience
that we had before,
and then it goes
out to production.
So, those mechanics
are a relatively sane.
What's different is that we're
trying to ship every day.
We're trying to ship a
mainline-built every day.
Out to production, it's monthly.
This cadence and
velocity is a lot
faster than what we
were able to do before.
Also, we have feature
toggles which
is brand new into Office 2016.
So, having Dart code and
then rolling it out and giving it
to our customers within the
build is brand new and it's
something that we've been
doing a lot of in Office 2016.
Just to make things
more complicated,
we also split our user-based
into different channels.
So, we have our monthly channel.
It's mainly consumers.
These people are
your mom and dad and
yourself maybe who've bought
your PC at Costco and
have Office on it.
You'll get updates every month
through the monthly
consumer channel.
The inner prizes are
a lot more risk averse.
So, they don't want to take
the cutting edge stuff.
They've never wanted to do that.
So, they take a build
every six months internally,
test it and then they deploy
that six month build within
the organizations for
stability reasons.
We are doing a lot
of investments in
enterprise in this space.
I won't talk about
it here too much,
but giving the visibility to
the enterprises of how
well the build is doing
within the organization
is something we've been
doing with Microsoft 365.
It's called, it's Microsoft 365.
If you look it up on the web,
it's interesting twist on
continuous deployment.
All right. So, there's a lot of
challenges with doing
continuous deployment
like I just described
with Office.
The codebase itself
is written in C++,
and a lot of it is 28-years-old.
So, the developers that are
working on Office right now,
a lot of them are younger
than the code itself.
So, things that we
take for granted or
Bing takes for granted,
for example, are just
not there in the code.
Telemetry, being one of them.
Oftentimes, when things break,
we're not sure how bad
it's broken because we
just don't have
the data to tell us.
We don't have a fast build
and release process.
Our build takes about five hours
and they worked really
hard to bring that down.
They did a great job doing that.
The ticket assigned
build that's tested,
it takes four days
and then getting that
filled out saturated
to all of our
protection audiences is
about 30 days on
the monthly channels.
Test coverage is another issue
with a such an old codebase.
The previous incarnations of
our organizations had
test organization.
Oftentimes,
manual tests were ran.
Person sitting in their Office
would click through the product,
it was never codified.
So, some of the tests
are just missing.
So, we don't have as much
confidence in the builds,
sometimes, if changes were made
in places that don't
have that coverage.
The DevOps pieces of
continuous deployment
that were talked about is
also challenging in Office
because as we build and
deploy these releases,
they are not in our data centers.
So, it's not a situation
where we have a previous,
current, and next
build that's deployed.
We have, the hundreds
of builds that we
produced and maintained in
all of the different
platforms out there.
Sometimes, with
shared code across
web, mobile, and Windows.
So, as an engineer who's
responsible for DevOps,
it's really hard to be able to
tell what version
of the code was it,
and what could be
really going wrong.
So, it's really challenging.
A lot of the differences
and challenges that
we have in moving
to continuous deployment
and integration has to
do with just historical
organizational culture.
The technologies that were
used in each one of
these different platforms,
so web and windows have
different telemetry stacks.
They have a different way of
ingesting and spitting
out telemetry.
So, you can't necessarily
compare the two of them.
So, we worked through trying
to standardize telemetry,
trying to standardize
the different metrics.
So, we'll have often
conversations about how
to get to one thing.
The different platforms also have
different philosophies
about what it
means to close up
build-blocking bug,
what it means to run unit tests.
The Mac team has a great culture
around unit tests.
They force every build to go run
all the unit tests and will
fail deployment if
anyone unit tests fails.
Windows is so big
and the unit tests are so
flaky that they don't even
want their unit tests to run.
So, the two different cultures
as they grew up over time,
just grew up with different ways
of handling situations.
We will run into
this almost daily,
but just people in a room having
different philosophies and having
to work through those issues.
Just to wrap up,
we have a lot of
market pressure to
continually develop
new functionality within Office.
Some of the cool features
around collaboration are
coming if you don't already
have them right now.
It's really fun to be in Office
and be able to deliver
these things in
this new world where
we're trying to ship
faster builds of the product.
Within there, we're also
investing in different ways
of developing Office experiences.
Laurie was talking about
other products also
having this challenge.
We have this really
old codebase, C++.
It's really expensive to
develop a new feature in
the core C++ environment
and then deploy it and get
it out to our customers.
So, we're looking
at different ways
of developing within Office.
Add-ins is a way that we're
also tackling this problem.
Add-ins are a third-party way
of adding to Office.
So, third parties
even in Office 2015,
they were able to add
new functionality to Office.
But it wasn't
the first class with
the Office developed
and deployed features,
but we're looking at
it as an avenue to
getting features out there
more quickly as a first party,
or Microsoft developers,
experience of adding to
Office through Add-ins.
Add-ins are used, it's
called the Agave framework.
If you search on the web,
you'll be able to find it
and it's JavaScript-based.
So, small packages
are delivered to
the client who run
JavaScript locally.
There's a huge effort
there to have
that as our next way of
adding features to Office,
and then we're doing
more service-based experiences
delivered to the clients.
The more obvious one
is the "Help".
At the very top, there's
a little light bulb
and you can ask question of
the service space
integration with client.
We have integrations with Bing.
When we do a service-based
integrations,
it's much easier
because we're able to
deploy a lot faster
and go through
the services delivery
pipelines instead
of dealing with
the big fat clients.
So, we're having a lot
of fun making Office,
optimizing what we do have,
finding new ways of getting
features out to customers.
Those are some of
our continuous deployment
in delivery stories.
Thanks.
>>So, we now do questions.
You can question the speakers.
>> Okay, does that work?
>> That's fine. Yes.
Say your name.
>> Great talks. Do I
have to push anything?
There we go. Great talks.
One of the questions I had,
you guys have heard of
the night group disaster
with feature toggles,
where they had
an old toggle turned on and
lost $460 million in 45 minutes.
So, how do you deal
with when you're
doing thousands of experiments,
how do you make sure
that this feature
is running on this person's
machine, on this server,
and this feature is running
on that server and they're
not sending any corrupted data
or doing something bad?
How do you deal with
the different combinations
of feature toggles?
>> My question. Yes.
So, my team owns
the feature toggle API for Office
and I have to say
it's really hard.
There is a ton of complexity
around what is being
tested in animation and
who has what and dog foods
who is a problem that
we do deal with.
My experience with Bing,
when I was in Bing
was that especially,
with experiments
having a control and
a treatment even if you
plan to ship the feature,
you're much more confident
in the fact that
it is the feature
that's causing
the problem and then you
focus on making the data faster.
So, all the signals
around crashes,
especially in Bing we
worked really hard
to get it down to minutes for
those really strong signals
of something going wrong
and ideally in Office we'll get
there. Do you have
something to add?
>> Yes, I think
Laurie's presentation
talked a little bit about it.
>> Yes, but it is
complex and you have
those guard rail metrics.
Basically, something's
wrong, shut it
off to try to prevent
something like that.
But I do think that we
need to acknowledge
the level of complexity
that is being put
into the code bases,
which is not something that
we traditionally have dealt with.
There are companies like
Facebook at the summit said
they they plan that
those feature toggles
will stay there forever,
they don't ever plan
to take them away.
So, the impact of that type
of development and
all of the company who
prevalently use feature toggle,
which is a lot, it's
a different way to develop.
We should be teaching
differently because of that.
>> We recognize at Bing that one
it's not even
just an experiment by
itself but one experiment can
have a side effect on
another existing experiment.
So, one of the final gates
to turning on an experiment
in production,
is we will rerun all of
the existing tests and
force that experiment,
in addition to
whatever experiments to
the test we're actually testing
so you get that coverage.
They'll know ahead of
time if any tests fail.
We expect them all to pass,
so they'll know ahead of
time if any tests fail.
They can look at
their results and decide
whether it's a transient issue,
or it's a real problem.
We also do the polite shutdown.
So there's a handful of business
specific critical metrics like
revenue that we will know within
a few minutes based on
the control and the treatment
and it just gets shut down.
It's an instantaneous shut down.
>> One of the
fundamental problems
in product development is
that a lot of the functionality
is almost never used.
So, that's not only
Microsoft products
but one of the problems.
We have looked into research to
study which functionality
could be taken out.
I wonder how the
continuous deployment,
continuous integration
paradigm accommodates
this idea. Is there any?
>> Dead code is
a problem if we're
doing it thousands of
experiments per month.
>> And that includes elimination.
>> It is dead code. I mean,
we would say comfortably
maybe 10 percent or
less of those experiments
as successful but we try.
Doesn't mean that when
the flight gets turned off,
or the experiment finishes
that they go and
clean up the code.
In fact, I've been doing work
myself to reclaim some of that,
some of the dead config and to
work with the partner
teams to clean
up their related code.
It's a problem, it's
a real problem.
It's a long-term problem that
just adds to our working set,
it slows our requests
down slightly,
and death of a thousand cuts.
Now we're 10 milliseconds slower,
now we're 20 milliseconds slower.
>> Yes, I think it's
an exciting development to have
things updated 100 times
in 100 milliseconds.
On the other hand, is it really
the the direction to
go to make it faster,
faster, faster, faster?
I mean, to me it
looks sometimes it is
very incremental changes and
we need on the other hand,
certainly, a more global
perspective on
the product, right?
We're all in it too.
>> It will interesting in
the long run what will happen
for that functionality
that was never used.
I've seen Standish
Group statistics
on that same thing and it's,
60 percent of the code,
the features are never used.
So hopefully, with
the experimentation then that is
discovered and the mechanism
are in place to just shut it off,
where before that
functionality was embedded in
the product and so you could
easily just shut it off.
So hopefully, that will be
the case and as mentioned,
I guess you said something like
10 percent of the experiments
are successes and Netflix
will say the same thing.
I think that you
had a study in a,
was it Office that
was 30 percent work?
>> It's Bing.
>> Bing, okay. So, there's
an acknowledgement that
a large percentage of
the features that are
developed are not deemed
to be an improvement.
So then, they are shut off which
would prevent the features
that are never used.
It doesn't prevent
the technical death.
>> Yes. But you may
have been asking
a slightly different question.
Are you saying that it's not
always best to chase latency,
that you may have
to sacrifice some
of it for feature richness?
>> Yes, in a way.
>> It's a real tension
that I feel on
my team because
owning the platform,
I am ultimately responsible
for the response time of
the server but
all the feature team
just want to get
their features out the door.
So, they're coding away
and yes, it's a problem.
>> We can not only be reactive,
we need to be proactive
to some extent in
latency. That is trade-off
>> Yes, the flights run
at a low percentage
so doesn't always
hit at our 95th,
the egregious ones
do and we work with
the partner teams to help improve
their latency in those cases.
>> Yes.
>> Kind of a slightly
different angle
on the same question.
This might be a little bit naive,
but as you're using metrics and
you're rapidly
releasing new features,
do you end up in
a local gradient descent where
you're improving whatever metrics
you're trying to improve?
You're getting a little bit
better and you find that
you're in this spot
where you found a product
that you want to optimize,
but you can't jump out of
that minimum because
any particular new feature that
you add is going to make
the experience worse
before you can get over
the hump and make it better.
Kind of the thing that prevents,
it's what causes disruptions
to be so disruptive
because there are
totally new paradigm
for whatever it is
you're competing with.
It's hard to get out of
that if you're doing
an incremental feature
improvement along the way.
That might be a naive way
of thinking about
the product development,
but it's something
that I wonder as
I hear your presentations.
As much as I think
it's awesome to
get millisecond deployments
on new features,
it's awesome but- thanks.
>> I think that there's
just two different paradigms.
We have to recognize that
you're not gonna get
a disruption from
incremental experiments,
that's why we do rely on
new products coming out
that don't necessarily
have to run
these experiments because
their user base is brand new.
Like Teams, for example,
the new product for-
that's a Slack competitor.
They started out without having
any, very many customers.
They do experiments now,
but when they first started out,
they weren't expected
to do experiments.
Their expectation was
to add a new product to
the ecosystem that grow
user base and then,
they're expected to
optimize the experience
once they have the users
to be able to do that.
So, I do think there's
just different places
where you apply the technologies.
>> But it's, I think
the same technology,
it's just used in
a different way,
so that's where dark launches.
So, it's behind a feature flag.
They can develop
a brand new disruptive feature
for a long period of time and be
deploying and continuously
integrating it,
but hiding it completely.
You know, Facebook definitely
talked about that,
so like Facebook Live video
or things like that.
I mean, they did
this continuous deployment,
and then started to experiment,
and then eventually, when
they were confident enough,
release it to all of us.
So, it's the same technique
to use for little changes
and big changes.
>> Stands I would've
given too, dark launch.
>> So, in Laurie's presentation,
she talked briefly about
Chaos Engineering.
I was wondering, does being
a Microsoft Office do
any sorts of these kind of
resilience testing in the field?
If yes, have you done anything to
minimize the impact of
the failure to those users?
>> Did you know what
Chaos Monkey is?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Yes. Short answer, yes.
We have multiple
different layers.
We do defense in depth, right?
So, we run all the tests
that we can upfront,
recognizing that everything's
going to get tested.
So, there are separate systems.
There's one that's continually
fuzzing, the live site.
Looking for issues, there's
a pen testing team
that goes and tries
to penetrate or defeat one or
more entry points on Bing.
There is a separate system,
as well that is periodically
just taking one of
our machines offline and seeing
what happens as a result.
So, there's many different
things that we're doing to
try to guarantee for the user
that we have
a consistent experience.
>> Okay.
>> Thanks. So, I'm curious about
how you got from
a 90-minute build down
to a 15-minute build?
Was that, I guess,
this was for
the Bing team, right?
Was that primarily
by migrating to
a Cloud-based Build technology or
did you do some
optimization elsewhere?
>> It was a combination of both.
So, there is an internal
Cloud Build system,
it's called Cloud Build.
>> Imagine that.
>> Because they figured it
should be descriptive, right?
That's the documentation,
actually it's just a file build.
There's a certain
amount of caching,
as well of previous targets
and they will pull in the cache.
A version of that has been
enabled for dev machine as well,
because the dev machine
doesn't have
multiple build servers, right?
But they will still use
the remote cache and
rebuild only the things
that we need.
But yet, there were
major changes in the way
that the code is laid
out in our system.
We have been consistently
moving stuff
out that the developers
don't care about.
In fact, there's even a flight
for a local build
that doesn't build
the test projects,
so that they can
get a faster build.
Yes, it's again, like with
anything else that I say,
it's going to be
defense in depth.
There's Cloud Build servers,
there's local stuff,
we've done a bunch
of optimizations
that could cleanup.
It's an ongoing process.
>> So, is there hope for
the five-hour Office build?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
>> But to be fair,
models that size,
you're only going to get
it down so far, right?
>> Yes.
>> This is where a remote build
actually would help
them more than with us.
In the initial days,
Cloud Build was great for us,
but now that we've minimized it
as much as we can
on the dev machine,
the paralyzed build servers
isn't helping us that much as.
>> Yes. Sorry, it's okay.
>> Yes. This discussion
of all the code behind
the feature of F5,
made me wonder about security.
It seems like there's
a different surface area
now for security texts.
You can change the value
of a flag and now you
expose code that wasn't
intended to be run.
Has there been work in
that space or even see
any real attacks in that space?
>> All right. I
understand what you're
saying and I have
not heard of that,
but I think it isn't real threat.
You just need to get
to the API, right?
Somehow, which is how
testing and production
often happen.
They get into the API
without going through
user interface,
so the threat isn't there.
I haven't heard any of
attacks that way though.
>> You're monitoring,
everything goes smoothly,
you would see a flag that
is on and you were like,
this is not ever
supposed to be on.
So, there's a lot,
I think, related to the toggles.
There's a lot of
monitoring of them.
>> Right, yes. So when
I talk about security,
I talk about
the instrumentation and
experimentation as a way to
say, "This is not right."
Whatever's happening right
now is not normal and then,
you might shut
something off to react,
but it also helps from
a security standpoint. Yes.
>> The security
starts with making
sure only certain people have
the ability to set flags.
Like, none of you are
going to be able to
go home and try to
force a specific experiment
or a feature for
being in our office.
Just not the way it
works like we only
allow that to happen
within our own machines.
It's controlled by IP.
Now, we have a way from
my office, sitting in my office,
which is inside
Microsoft's Cortana,
I could force myself onto
an experiment but it's
only enabled for those people.
>> Hi, thanks. So, this shift
from no experimentation to
virtually continuous
experimentation that
you are going through,
seems to suggest to me that
you also need a shift
in mindset of
your engineers from
an engineering centric mindset
to a scientist centric mindset,
somebody that thinks
about experiments.
Do you see that in
your employees,
and did your recruitment change
to accommodate this more?
>> The culture of experimentation
has definitely changed.
People thinking about putting
their changes behind
the flight has changed,
whereas before they
would just push it,
now they actually understand,
"Let's do this incrementally
and make sure we
don't mess up the live site
for everybody else."
There is so much detail on
our scorecards that
it would stagger you,
even faculty, even the
academia you'd be staggered
by how many metrics we have
available on
a scorecard for Bing.
So, they highlight the ones
with the highest
confidence interval
and they make decisions
based on that.
>> I was asking how has your
recruitment process changed,
to accommodate for people
that think this way,
that think in terms
of experiments as
opposed to people that think
in terms of code perhaps.
>> I don't think
recruiting has changed
much since it's learned
experience, right?
Like we're hiring for
their technical talent and they
learned flighting on the way.
>> But we had a big transition
from testing data scientists,
I mean in terms of HR, didn't we?
I mean that, in Microsoft,
my understanding was like a lot
of folks who were doing testing,
the testing discipline
became more
oriented toward data science
and actually we had
job title changes
and all that sort of
thing happen, yes?
I thought we went through
a pretty big transition.
>> I can talk to that in
terms of being on
an experimentation team,
for Bing and for Office.
The culture is hard but let's
put that hiring part aside.
A culture change
is very difficult.
In Bing, that's the way
they live in breath,
engineers there know when
the experimentation review is,
they know how to go there,
they know how to
intelligently have
a conversation about P values,
and what statistics means.
In Office, it's very
much further away.
One, the set of metrics
is not as stable,
it's not largely
recognized across
the organization that those set
of metrics are important,
and they are shape
blocking or not.
So, we're working through
that with Office and just
educating both the IC engineers,
as well as the managers about how
it works and why it's important.
To Tom's point
about data science,
we have sets of
data scientists with
varying different backgrounds.
There's testers that were
turned into data scientists.
I would say that some of
their statistical
knowledge is less,
than say data scientists
that we hired that has
no computer science
background but is
a biology major, for example.
So there's varying degrees of
statistical ability,
in that sense.
Hiring wise though,
as a developer,
you need the skill sets of
just being able to
code in C++ build,
be diligent, be able to go
deep, understand architecture.
The statistics part is important
but it isn't what we would
necessarily hire for.
Data savviness is probably
something that we would
look for or ask about.
>> I mean not just developers,
but also someone who they
call a product owner.
I mean, there is
a definite shift there,
and this is among some of
the companies who are now,
there is a hypothesis.
So, you want this function,
you want this new feature,
what's your hypothesis?
What would change
if you got that?
Let's specify that as a metric.
So, that's like a whole
different type of process.
Sometimes product owners are
technical people but sometimes
they are business-oriented
but they have to have
this new mindset to deal
with experimentation.
>> You could even turn
that question around and say,
"Do you need experts
in data science?
Could your
experimentation platform
be made simple enough that
anyone could understand it
without data science degree?"
That's what we aim for and anyone
should be able to do
an experiment in Bing.
That's not always the case but.
>> I'm just looking at
the time, so last question.
>> Yes.
>> More importantly
the data science
reminds me very much statistics.
There's no surprise that in
schools you have bio-statistics,
you have physical
statistics for physics,
you have engineering statistics
of different discipline
because data depends on
how you collect the data,
what representation
you make in the data,
whether it's
symbolic representation,
whether it's numeric,
whether it's any
other representation.
Then, what questions
you are going to ask.
That depends on the domain.
So, yes, computer scientists have
a role there but they just have,
I don't want to put any number
but they just have a role.
But it really is a
discipline dependent,
what data is going
to be collected and what
questions will you be asking.
>> Or product dependent, right?
The products are different.
MSN set of data scientists
have a different product
than Office does.
So, you have to be able to
ask the right questions.
What does it mean in Office,
in terms of subscription users
and enterprise users
versus MSN is
a primarily media based?
That must be a little challenge
for a company like
Microsoft that wants
to sell a platform,
that is covers
a much broader audience.
Nevertheless, you'll have to
be realistic, what to expect.
>> I think on that point
can we thank speakers
again? Thank you
very much for coming